[Musica]
sono certa che tutti voi sappiate che
questa
è una sedia ergonomica
e sono anche certo che molti di voi
abbiano già provato questi pantaloncini
per la bici dal design ergonomico
forse però pochi di voi sanno che anche
i jeans che indosso sono ergonomici
grazie a queste cuciture danno comfort e
libertà il movimento
ecco questi oggetti hanno più fare con
il benessere fisico delle persone
ma se vi dicessi che possono essere
ergonomici anche altri oggetti ben più
complicati come per esempio i software
con leon elementi grafici visivi tassi e
bottoni che utilizziamo quando usiamo un
computer un telefonino
oppure che possono essere ergonomici
interi complessi sistemi di lavoro per
esempio come reagireste
io ma forse questo lo avete già intuito
sono l'ergonomia e non mi occupo degli
oggetti semplici come le sedie
pantaloncini bensì di come rendere il
lavoro
adeguato le persone
e nonostante il fatto lo faccia più da
vent'anni è proprio la domanda intorno
alla mia professione quella che mi mette
sempre in difficoltà
fin basti pensare che addirittura mia
mamma natale in tavola sempre il
discorso vale sia la mia professione
confidando nell'aiuto di amici e parenti
ma incomincio a pensare che con lei non
ci sia più speranza
visto che ritengo utile e importante
rendersi conto di quante cose e
situazioni intorno a noi sono progettate
a misura d'uomo e di donna e di quanti
invece non lo siano ancora vorrei
raccontarvi di cosa si occupa mergono ma
come me che ha lavora in ambito
cognitivo ed organizzativo
ergonomia cognitiva si occupa del
benessere non fisico bensì mentale delle
persone
affinché il carico di lavoro non sia
eccessivo
l'obiettivo è fare in modo che ciò che è
richiesto dall attività richiede giusti
livelli di attenzione e che le persone
abbiano tutto ciò che serve nella
posizione in cui serve per procedere con
facilità e senza troppo sforzo
questo è possibile progettando strumenti
anche digitali adeguati alle persone
ambienti e spazi operativi e dedicati al
relax adeguati alle persone
l'ergonomia cognitiva e poi quelle
organizzato organizzativa si occupano
anche di progettare processi di lavoro
quali compiti le procedure i flussi di
comunicazione per esempio
lavoriamo sempre in team anche con
designer architetti ingegneri
informatici e negli ergonomie portiamo
nel progetto la voce delle persone
quella voce che ci racconta delle loro
esigenze e bisogni
delle loro caratteristiche uniche
quella voce che ci racconta le loro
storie nel loro contesto
per farvi capire quanto sia
diversificata l'attività di un ergonomo
vorrei raccontarvi l'origine della mia
scelta
alla fine delle superiori
leysin articolo che parlava delle stanze
del futuro che sarebbero state sentite
un po
intelligenti
ebbene sì in grado di captare e
percepire le esigenze delle persone da
adattarvisi
predisponendo automaticamente un
ambiente adatto quella persona in
termini di temperatura colori ambiente
musica con l'articolo diceva anche che
questi venti sarebbero stati in grado di
predisporre un servizio su misura
una cena in caso di appetito o un bagno
caldo in caso di bisogno di relax
ed è proprio qui che si esprime la vera
intelligenza di questi ambienti quando
pressano tutta questa attenzione alle
persone e alle loro esigenze
ed è proprio questa la grande differenza
che sento da altre processioni che
intervengono sulla vita e sul lavoro
delle persone
rimasi quindi molto colpita da come
tutto il sistema tecnologico fosse in
grado di percepire ed adattarsi e
predisporsi per il benessere delle
persone e fu in quell'articolo che lessi
per la prima volta la parola ergonomia
usata per descrivere ambienti in grado
di adattarsi gentilmente alle persone
e decisi così di occuparmi di persone
progettando tecnologie oggetti ambienti
e spazi umani
di cosa parliamo quando parliamo di
ergonomia
un po
ve l'ho già raccontato ma vorrei
focalizzare meglio con voi dicendovi che
è l'ergonomia è quella disciplina che si
occupa delle attività delle persone
e lì come vengono realizzate
si applica la conoscenza scientifica per
risolvere i problemi che le persone
incontrano nelle attività usando gli
oggetti di tutti i giorni
e quando parliamo di attività parliamo
di tutti i tipi di attività della nostra
vita di apprendimento di divertimento di
cura di sport
io in particolare mi occupo di benessere
sul lavoro
ma come fa
l'ergonomia a fare tutto ciò
progettando mettendo le persone al
centro proprio come l'ha descritto in
quell'articolo
le persone sono l'asset principale il
bene più importante delle organizzazioni
il loro benessere e lo scopo del lavoro
economico
l'innovazione la tecnologia sono meri
strumenti per raggiungere questo scopo
l'approccio ergonomico rispetto
all'essere umano e crea esperienze di
vita e di lavoro positive e valorizzanti
ricerca l'equilibrio e trova un modo per
migliorare la situazione delle persone
ma cosa fanno
virgo nomi e l'ergonomia nella pratica
immaginiamo le coinvolti nella
progettazione di un sistema di lavoro
per il quale occorre ripensare
strumenti tecnologie spazi arredamenti
ma anche tempi e modi di lavoro un
ergonomo comincerà sempre dall'osservare
osservare cosa
forse potresti chiedermi e le persone
cosa fanno e come lo fanno
le persone verranno affiancate nella
loro attività nel loro quotidiano nel
loro contesto per scoprire cosa accade e
come
a volte basterà poco tempo a volte sarà
necessario immergersi nella loro realtà
per molti giorni
verranno osservate le interazioni tra le
persone gli strumenti di attività
immaginatevi un nervoso ma anche un po
come l'etnografia che si immerge attenta
rispettose curiosa in un ambiente di
lavoro come se fosse un villaggio
sconosciuto che si fa ombra di chi ci
lavora che affianca le persone
l'intervista raccoglie informazioni e
documenti dati utili per capire
l'attività e le condizioni di tempo e di
risorse
le esigenze ei problemi che possono
causare
malessere e disagio
ma ve lo immaginate come sarebbe bello
se qualcuno si sintonizzasse così da
vicino con voi per capire la vostra
attività con l'estero scopo di
migliorarla e farvi stare meglio
che bello sarebbe se qualcuno si
interessasse la nostra fatica fisica e
mentale e ci chiedesse se la nostra
attività è in linea con le nostre
competenze e possibilità o che
addirittura ci chiedesse qual è il
significato che attribuiamo al nostro
fare in quel contesto
per me non è solo un metodo di lavoro è
proprio una visione del mondo che parte
dalla situazione delle persone cerca di
migliorarla
quale sarà allora il mio principale
strumento di lavoro
il mio principale strumento di lavoro e
l'ascolto l'empatia
l'ascolto come strumento conoscitivo e
l'empatia come strumento che mi fa
entrare relazione con le persone
rispettando la loro unicità e non
sostituendo mia loro
si procede dal basso dai casi reali
dalla situazione che vivono le persone
con le loro esigenze loro punti di vista
i loro linguaggi per capire ciò che
accade e come
l'empatia che apertura mentale e di
cuore e sospensione del giudizio sarà
anche lo strumento che mi permetterà di
far convergere su una decisione
condivisa le esigenze di tutti gli
attori del progetto ciascuno con le
esigenze differenti
a questa fase di osservazione arriverà
un'altra fase focalizzata ad indy vari
perché le cose accadono proprio così e
faremo molta attenzione a intoppi
criticità problemi che le persone
incontrano e udite udite dal cappello
del ergonomo usciranno anche le esigenze
latenti quelle di cui le persone non
sono a conoscenza
dopo questa fase l'ergonomia teresa
disposizione del team di lavoro
una fotografia
un'immagine un film inedito
attraverso la condivisione del quale si
possa giungere
alla consapevolezza
solo dopo la consapevolezza è possibile
avere un processo reale di cambiamento
e solo dopo aver visto il film è
possibile ipotizzare una
costellazione di possibili risposte
l'ergonomia si fa carico del cambiamento
ed è responsabile così di ciò che
progetta con e per le persone
si tratta di un processo iterativo
virtuoso circolare che procede provando
e riprovando ed è potenzialmente
infinito
insomma un percorso per prendersi cura
delle persone c'è di operiamo senza
sosta per il loro equilibrio e il loro
benessere
la più grande lezione che ho imparato
dall'ergonomia e che può essere
applicata a qualsiasi contesto a
qualsiasi cosa che ci circonda noi
stessi possiamo guardarci con occhi
diversi
entrare in empatia con noi stessi e
trovare un modo per migliorare la nostra
situazione
mettendoci sempre al centro
siete pronti per diventare un pargolo
mia anche voi
osservate vehicle occhi diversi
osservate il vostro contesto e
chiedetevi è davvero pensato per me è
davvero ciò di cui ho bisogno
quando c'è o non c'è economia
fateci caso
grazie
[Applauso]